planet Earth the winds of change are
rippling across its surface taxi cabs in
New York are going hybrid lightbulbs in
Australia are going fluorescent the
whole of Vatican City is going carbon
neutral all around the globe
many of us are focused on changing our
ways because last year we accepted that
the earth itself is changing and all 6.6
billion of us are the cause assessing
the Earth's health isn't quite as simple
as taking its temperature and with
varying climates populations and
economic circumstances ecological issues
don't always divide along national
borders but by culling and carefully
comparing the best data from
organizations like the United Nations
the Nature Conservancy and the world's
top research centres and universities
the EPI team believes they're
establishing a meaningful baseline where
a complicated animal this planet we've
got lots of different pulses but I'd
also tell you that we're confident that
we are presenting the cleanest clearest
best picture of the state of the planet
that is available today
beginning with that blanket of nitrogen
oxygen and other gases stretching 348
miles above our heads our atmosphere
it's those gases not our oceans that
give earth its blue hue from space and
over the past 250 years the levels of
greenhouse gases like carbon dioxide and
methane have grown greater than any time
in the previous 650,000 years Mike Fay
is a conservationist and National
Geographic explorer-in-residence carbon
accumulated for well over something like
200 million years on this planet and in
the last kind of 60 80 years we have
burned probably a hundred million years
worth of accumulated carbon for decades
scientists and politicians have argued
over the exact causes and implications
of this increase but on February 2nd
2007 the fighting stopped after six
years reviewing all available research
hundreds of climate experts for more
than a hundred countries including the
United States issued a report through
the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change that confirms the Earth's air and
sea temperatures are climbing and that
the burning of fossil fuels and other
human activities like deforestation are
driving the change having to admit that
that is true is a milestone there's no
doubt about that D they can no longer
deny it and so now what we need to do is
go from recognition of the problem to
action
carbon dioxide and other greenhouse
gases are vital components of our
atmosphere
trapping enough solar heat to make life
possible but as we pump more and more of
these gases into the air we trap more
heat and the world gets warmer already
we've warmed up the earth by about 0.8
degrees Celsius and if we continue
emitting co2 into the atmosphere at the
same rate that's likely to climb some
two to four degrees higher by the
beginning of the next century